difficile de les rater samedi la troupe
de lascars avant bouveret la parade du
festival un sens et une déambulation de
l'université versailles saint quentin au
centre commercial
l'idée c'était de créer un événement
fédérateur en arrivant à contacter les
associations locales de saint quentin en
yvelines
les associations étudiantes est vraiment
de pouvoir construire un événement tous
ensemble est un événement qui nous
ressemble à un événement qui est pour
saint quentin en yvelines pour ses
habitants et donc pour nous c'était
important de créer cette dynamique
culturelle vraiment entre chaque acteur
de l'événement
une dizaine d'associations saint
quentinois s'étaient donné rendez vous
deux d'entre elles pour un projet commun
pris en compte
deux ans de travail pour vivre debout et
les black blanc beur pour fêter donc à
rotor avions décidé de faire un
événement festif faire la fête et faire
la fête autour en fait de vos histoires
personnelles de ce qui nous est arrivé
dans la vie les bonnes et des mauvaises
choses mais raconter ça avec humour est
et d'une façon agréable ça a été fait
sur la base de mathieu donc moitié notre
graphe qui a un petit peu
conduire lagarde travail chorégraphique
en fait et puis elle nous on s'est
greffée à deux ans en fait quoi tout
simplement
voilà donc ces beaux dirais je dirais
que c'est beaucoup plus ainsi de nous
adapter à leur situation
eux de s'adapter à notre manière de
bouger en fait soleil et instant de
bonne humeur pour l'arrivée du printemps
où l'on a même vu en géant tombé
amoureux